because this whole 20-25 minute stretch
that we're talking about you could
pretty much dub peter's lesson about
great power comes great responsibility
that's that whole see from from before
ant-may dies to the end of this scene
when they're chatting with each other
that to me is more rewarding than them
quipping that to me is more rewarding
than them having fun doing spider-man
stuff because this is peter parker's
talking with each other well using and
resting upon all of the character
development and all the details that
have come in those movies before and so
it feels like yeah an immediate way to
go no no we care about all three of
these peters yeah but also we care most
about what's happening to tom's peter
right here and now to me it thematically
represents peter parker spider-man the
the most and is easily the most
emotionally effective and gives you the
best range of emotions from heartbreak
sorrow
to
cheer
joy wonder
the wonder uh yeah it does it all
[Music]
get ready to see me in this wardrobe a
lot over the next few days
ever since i got this epic hero shop
shirt they're not asking me to plug it
but i've been craving it alright ladies
and gentlemen spider-man no way home is
finally out this is not a full-on
spoiler talk we are going to do a live
stream spoiler talk this coming monday
11 a.m pacific standard time koi zhandra
will be joining both john and i it's
going to be very in-depth breakdown what
i wanted to do today though there's a
like a
25-minute chunk of this movie that i
i've been craving to discuss with you
guys so right now it it at least in
filming this this video is titled
spider-man away home our favorite
moments there's so much to talk about
here like there's chunks of the first
half of this movie that i particularly
love and there's another universe for
this video could just be called the
second half of spider-man no way oh my
like oh it's pretty much almost perfect
for me that whole second half just when
i'm going about my day there is a
certain chunk of this film a very
specific couple sequences that are that
are put back to back that my mind is
always going to so i just wanted to
focus strictly and talk about why i
think that chunk is perfect we're gonna
talk a lot about the other things that
are definitely favorite moments from the
film come this monday and maybe
throughout some like other videos giving
little talks about it here and there but
i wanted to focus specifically on this
in the meantime you guys can while
you're listening why don't you leave
down in the comments what your favorite
scene from the movie is yeah we could
finally talk about some spoilers here i
don't know here we go exciting with the
cat out of the bag where it kicks off
for me where this movie really has just
a a definite shift in mood and tone i
feel like it it smoothly gets there i
don't think it's jarring after jay jonah
jameson learns where peter parker is he
leaves a daily bugle and one thing i'll
add too is i really like the way how jay
jonah is captured in this movie it's
kind of communities are like the
spider-man video game where you hear him
as sort of this like he you know we call
spider-man a menace but he's really like
this menacing narrator throughout
helping to add on to that tainted public
image of peter parker throughout this
film you see him out in the van getting
out and it's handheld you're like i've
never seen this side of j jonah before
right yeah it's a great wraparound for
the movie and it really felt like
something that would be interjected in a
comic book as well this like consistent
narration but it's in universe it's
diegetic it's after jay jonah shows up
they're walking out of the van it's
handheld and then you get to this point
with peter parker's spider sense where
it's captured in a motif that i often uh
pulls me out of a movie now because it's
used so often but i thought it was used
to a more unique effect that mounted
shot where he's looking around the room
but it's different because you're seeing
it in a really sinister version of him
having his spider sense being activated
and at first what's cool what's clever
about that is it has you thinking is
this because jay jonah's outside and
then he's looking around the room and
you're not even exactly sure
what's going on or what his suspicions
are but i love the use of of the audio
in that you know remember it all kind of
just sort of goes out it's a bit muffled
and echoey looking around all the
villains he sort of has to do a
meditative spot where he has to listen
to his senses he has to listen to his
feelings yeah before he webs goblin what
was so cool about that when green goblin
starts to to come out like you really
thought you could suppress your other
half every time i've seen this and we've
seen this three times by now i start to
question like what exactly is the moment
that he stopped being norman osborne and
green goblin started taking over again
and just pretended to be norman osborne
you know because in the theaters i can't
remember exactly what the line is but
when it's doc ock and norman and they're
working in the science room after doc
ock's um inhibitor chip has been
repaired he says something to uh norman
something no more no more darker half or
something like that yeah it's this shot
from behind norman as he and then he
replies to him and i forget exactly what
that line is every time we've watched it
everyone in the crowd goes oh
[ __ ] yeah
that's like that's when they they hint
at it but then when it cuts back to him
you're like okay nevermind i guess he's
fine they've done such a good job on
investing you and norman that you don't
want him to go back to being green
goblin that was an effect i didn't
actually like expect to happen with this
film when you know green goblin is
giving this speech about like i've been
watching you through norman's eyes
thinking you could have all you want
it's maybe not be the most
hyper stylized choreography of the movie
but the fight sequence that it breaks
out into is easily the most gritty handy
yeah that's when you know we were
talking in the non-spoiler about how a
lot of the action actually feels like
violence and i think both of our minds
specifically flash to that sequence
everything with goblin especially
because even towards the end it's like
those fights in particular take on a
much more rough and painful edge it's
funny because i thought of suicide squad
but i love just how they're crashing
through floor after floor and you feel
the weight of just all that rubble and
debris and how painful this is for both
of them well i think in the choreography
one of the cool parts is when he like
webs him flips and crashes him down on
the balcony floor yeah and he gets on
top of goblin and he's like punching him
he's like does that thing that usually
you see like female superheroes yeah
wrap their legs around the guy's head
and punch them it was in that moment
where i actually started thinking of the
dark knight of what they've done with
goblin it specifically started coming to
fold in this scene because on my third
re-watch it was like oh okay and knowing
what's gonna happen next with anime it
was making me think of dark knight and
i'll bring that back a little bit later
after goblin gets out of the room and i
loved how you could tell it's willem
dafoe really doing the fight scenes big
respect cause i saw that clip where he
said like i'll do this but you have to
let me participate in as much of the
action as i can because that's part of
the a the fun for me and b how i can
really bring all of my you know talent
and energy to this character and you
really feel that it shows it feels
visceral physical is how i would say it
one moment that every time i watch it it
just is such a really badass moment from
peter parker is when he's limping
through the hallway he's all messed up
there's the window he's trying to go
outside and he just
goes like he webs really fast and just
shatters the glass by pulling it there's
something about just watching this guy
struggle like that kind of makes me
think of like daredevil the hallway
fight of like struggling but trying to
keep on fighting so that's like a really
physical representation of peter parker
to me that i've been craving from these
mcu films i haven't seen that in any of
the spider-man films just something that
feels very realistic about the use of
the webbing yeah grabs the window you
know that shot yeah and it also plays
into his just creativity based on his
knowledge of science and physics because
it's like yeah you don't necessarily
have to throw something i can i have the
range advantage i can just clear this
obstacle from right here yeah so when he
goes outside and then it's all like
crashing upon him this is like the
collapse of everything for him the
helicopter's out on him jay jonah's
smiling looking up at him like i got you
and then lizard comes down and that's
like what if if i have i do have
criticisms about this movie particularly
they mainly come from sections i'd say
or like
moments from the first half not really
full-on scenes there's no scenes i don't
like lizard uh he the the one scene i
can say i confidently like is actually
that brief moment of him there when he
appears it's the best he looks in the
film and he says i told you there'd be
consequences peter and i'm like that's
why they hear everybody yeah that's why
he hit outside he didn't believe in this
most nuanced least boilerplate line as a
character lizard in that moment yeah so
then eventually it gets to um a scene
that everyone in the theater cries you
know it's damn good storytelling when
you hear about this plot point it got
leaked uh we knew about it
uh but damn i i gotta say that scene
every time i watch it especially this
the second time for some reason because
we saw it with the smaller crowd i was
able to just kind of sit back and take
it in and hear more of the dialogue yeah
i was just bawling my eyes out that's
what really reminds me of of joker and
and i if i remember correctly a part of
uh marvel comics when it came to like
what is the answer for spider-man's
joker then they created like green
goblin it's kind of cool to see how they
had like jack nicholson play a more
campy version of joker and heath ledger
comes in as the realistic more realistic
grounded gritty version and willem dafoe
got to do both yeah
he really does and he gets to in a way
that still feels naturally like it's
coming out of the character from 2002
like it doesn't feel like a reinvention
but it does feel more akin to the movies
and the style we expect now yeah and i
love that they kept his mask off for it
so when he
you know he sees aunt may and you could
tell he's plotting to kill her he has
real dark night vibes like the whole
thing with like punching goblin and he's
just laughing maniacally as he's getting
hit because he knows peter can't kill
him he's pretty much saying that the
thing that's holding you back from
unleashing your darkness and becoming
your fullest potential because he keeps
saying you know you have all the power
in the world but you're too weak to kill
me he kills aunt may kind of like batman
having his rachel be killed in the dark
knight and there's also something about
the mood and the way it's shot that does
have a little bit more of that nolan
gritty comic book real vibe about it
yeah but when ant-mate dies uh when she
gets hit by the glider it does a it's a
good trick on you because she gets hit
and everyone's oh oh no when goblin
swings off after the explosion of the
pumpkin bomb she gets back up peter gets
back up and i remember the first time i
watched like oh
they faked me out league must have been
fulfilled
part of the scene and assumed or
something yeah and you know people were
always saying like are you reading these
leaks how are you going to enjoy the
movie if any of that comes true and i
feel like yeah as much as it does suck
to be able to anticipate something if
the movie is doing or the show or
whatever is doing a good job of really
pulling you in and keeping the nuance
high you know moments like that can
still hit just as hard and can still
throw you to the point where you're like
okay maybe it won't happen yeah i think
one thing john watts does exceptionally
well in this movie is michael giochino's
score is some of the best the mcu has
ever had but he's really great in in
this particular film of knowing when to
have no music and really let the scene
which specific scenes to truly let
breathe and feel the mood and the
tension of the sequence like you could
feel the rubble you could feel the fire
crackling you could feel the dirt the
atmosphere the grind like everything
about after the rubble is there and
ant-man and peter are like struggling to
get up and peter thinks it's fine
there's no music it's just this you can
just have this scene with there the part
that gets me to crack
is
you know when peter is like saying this
is all my phone my god it's happening to
me
yeah peter is starting to crack
first are talking about like oh [ __ ] my
arms are turning water i need a whole
bag
no don't hold back but so look
[Laughter]
i think why it hits me harder on the
second time is because i'm fully aware
she's dying in this moment
and in her dying
moments when peter is doubting what he
was trying to set out to do with curing
them
and knowing that she's dying then she
says nothing norma's no no when she says
the line like with great power
comes great responsibility i'm getting
teary too i just started
the second time i watched it i was like
she's dying right now
and she's using her like some of her
final words to give him his most
powerful message yeah that he's ever
needed to give him that push and i'll
tell you this i think it's
way more effective and this is what
surprised me too is that they gave that
line to her instead of an uncle ben i
think it's better than any of the uncle
ben's uh that particular scene of the
use of great power great responsibility
instilling that message then spider-man
1 and the amazing spider-man that moment
is so effective well there's something
about placing it really within the
moment of pain and peril and defeat i
think that like in the other and her
concern is all about him at that moment
not even about her yeah and it would be
a really easy human choice to be like if
this guy just impaled me with a glider
you know you could let that hate take
over or whatever and
they don't and but it's yeah in the
previous movies those exchanges happen
in calm moments before the tragedy peter
isn't there for whereas here it's at the
most heavy crucial point in the movie
and yeah it's that last ounce of what's
great about especially this movie's may
we've had some discussions about the
different kind of ups and downs of how
they portray her motivations and her
understanding of him as spider-man but
here i think it rings the loudest and
the truest because we've had such a
build up over three movies and then yeah
in this moment where it would be so easy
to succumb to everything around you she
still gives him that anti-joker push
that no no no no keep going you've got
greatness in you but you can't let this
moment crush that and i think what's
brilliant about marissa tommy's
performance in that is that she's not
playing up the pain no she's trying
she's trying to hide it she's trying to
hold it in and and there's like shock in
there there's shocking there's probably
a concussion here yeah like she plays
that daze really well so that yeah the
reality is all in peter like the the
crushing heartbreaking realities all in
peter and i feel like as he leaves her
you can see one of i feel like it's one
of his teardrops rolling down her face i
know she she he leaves already and then
it cuts back to her and then she's then
she is i think the tear does come from
her eye oh i thought either way either
way it's still effective but i think
like when peter is crying and talking to
her normally what makes me cry are
actually not death scenes for some
reason it it's really like acts of love
that will make me crass by that great
power great responsibility but when he
is losing her like that is his final
loss you know in the film when he's
losing her and the way the the realism
of that is done where he's you know he
just he can't believe it he can't accept
it there's certain lines that he's
saying that are not coming to me right
now and i'm usually bawling when i'm
watching it
it's just
just talk to me like what are you doing
what are you doing why are you working
we're gonna get through this it's gonna
be fine you know so it's so powerful and
then and then peter gets shot by a gun
seconds later by the department of
damage control it is
it's some of the most mature moments of
the entirety of the mcu in particular
and one of the most powerful mature
scenes from the spider-man universe uh
just in general all the spider-man films
i would say when he goes off then it you
know cut like i'm not going to argue
with the logic of it's it's a death
scene so there's going to be pouring
rain all right
it always rains when superheroes have
major deaths yeah so moments later it's
pouring rain but the thing is like i
didn't even think about that till the
third time and it still doesn't bother
me at all someone said that to me i'm
like it rains in new york it rains all
right poor rain because the way that
shot is so
beautiful yeah yeah and it's like his
you could see his tears through the rain
and it just looks like out of a comic
book with this massive scale of
television
jumbotron him looking at jonas saying
like everything peter touches is bad
yeah and it comes to ruin it's in that
moment he's believing that he truly
truly believes that after the most
devastating moment of the film the most
dark moment and the most devastating we
cut to mj and ned who are
looking for peter it's a good transition
it's a smooth transition when they start
saying like i would i just wish i could
see him and he does a sling
and then another one and then you see in
the in the alleyway i don't know why
it's not raining for for andrew
so you see him in the you see him in the
alleyway and it it usually takes a
couple seconds for for most people
to realize
that's oh it's a different
we have to be sure in terms of being
with an audience it is the most
rewarding and i'm so happy they did
andrew's first yeah because you see him
running it's such an exciting moment
like this like yeah truth be told this
movie does work best if you watch all
the movies first before you watch this
one but when andrew starts running in
and he jumps to the world everyone's
clapping and they're just waiting
they're just waiting for the real
confirmation yeah
it's not really confirmed until the
match could be another time yeah
he takes the mask off and it's andrew
garfield's face it is like the best it's
that to me because honestly and i i
don't know if i'd get some
i don't know i feel that andrew garfield
love has come around a lot more lately
before no way home and i i i have to
factor in tom holland's amazing
performance in this one but before no
way home andrew garfield shot up to be
my favorite peter parker spider-man when
i did my re-watch a lot of my rankings
had actually changed a lot on my rewatch
of them so i was just personally really
excited to see him the reason why i
think it's perfect for andrew garfield
to be the first spider-man to show up is
because an amazing spider-man 2 a big
part of his debate that andrew garfield
has with harry osborn is i think
spider-man is trying to give people hope
inspire hope in people and then when he
has the scene with dane dehaan where
he's rejecting giving him his blood dana
hans like i thought you were supposed to
give people hope i thought you know all
that so to that effect you have the most
devastating hopeless scene and then the
first feeling of hope and optimism is
the guy whom the last movie we saw him
in was struggling to give people hope he
shows up hope is reinstilled right away
yeah yeah absolutely and he brings i
love the dynamic of of the three of them
but yeah i love that he also kind of has
a journey to be on as well he's kind he
is like the perfect middle child in that
you know toby is a bit more sage and
andrew has still got some darkness to
work through but he's been through
enough that he can impart his wisdom on
tom's spider-man and really i don't know
a dark note for him and an amazing spot
right here absolutely it does yeah and
and yeah it was really nice that he is
the brightest most bubbly of the three
of them because it makes a lot of sense
but also i think it's just really nice
to see him back in a way where we can
really enjoy the fun of his peter parker
because you know tasm 2 does get pretty
dark pretty heavy for him to have him be
the intro to that it was i think the
exact right choice the whole sequence
the way they have fun with it they don't
just have them start doing crazy
spider-man stuff right away what i
respected so much is that i was thinking
that when they would show up in the
movie if they did would be kind of quick
and fun
typical mcu fan service like it'd be
fast yeah you know but they're really
supporting characters
yeah when they show up so when he shows
up and he's getting acquainted with
everything i think to just nail the
introduction of how his version of
spider-man would handle being in this
situation enamored with the mystical
side of it you know being told like i
think the way zendaya and jacob battle
on the way they interact with him at
first when she's like throwing the bread
yes and saying improve your spider-man
crawling and get the web on the on the
side and then of course toby shows up
right you do another poor home like i
can't believe they're doing this back to
back and in terms of effective fan
service to have it be first we just get
them to alone and yeah yeah before we
have them meet up with tom holland
i love that because you know like you
said he's more sage he's got a little
bit more wisdom toby mcguire's version
gotta take a little bit of time to kind
of adjust to his new look
and you know i mean that's where some of
the mechanics get a little uh muddy
because they do let him it seems just be
aged up you know they let him be at the
what arguably would be the present for
his toby maguire or for his peter parker
yeah because they don't really give you
a clue as to like what's happened with
his future but they kind of give clues
to andrew garfield which we're gonna get
into in a second and i like how you know
toby's is much much more subdued more
subtle portrayal of peter parker and he
maintains that here and his aged up more
wisdom
style works for for this one because i
was like how would his energy work for
an mcu film and it works here and i do
love how the way they have fun with it
when they do like web each other at each
other they flip it's just like a little
tease like are they gonna fight oh you
know they don't i don't think the peters
would so when he's saying like i'm go
looking for him and they're reflecting
on empire state building the chrysler
and then they cut to tom holland on top
of the building he's when he's just
crying like it shifts you back into tom
hall's perspective and i think that's
one thing this film does really well is
that the other spiderman don't outshine
tom holland still and that was like a
big concern of mine walking into this
movie but he's there and it makes me cry
again when when he's just sitting there
and then when zendaya shows up to hug
him he starts bawling again because
that's such a realistic way of how we'll
probably go down most movies would
probably happen just be there still
really crying but it's really when
someone's about to hug you where you can
let that wall down again and just let
your feelings out and his best friends
are holding him you can see he senses
the other two so and they sense each
other and i feel like you know again i
can hear some people's gripes and
potentially about some of that but i do
think that was a really nice choice of
like yeah i i had a sense that someone
really needs our help and he's one of me
the way that they're able to tap into
that throughout the movie but especially
in this portion of introduction and in
this you know harsh you know emotional
kind of confrontation i think that was a
really nice aspect and a way to hone in
on the spider sense because i feel like
one of the gripes about the tom holland
movies is that they haven't made a ton
of
creative use out of that and and they
really did hear in a lot of ways and i
mean going back really super quick i
mean you mentioned the shot that kicks
this whole thing off of him locked off
kind of honing in on his sense but what
i love the kind of the most about that
is and what sells that part of it is
really nauseatingly long crush zoom the
way that that really hones the sense in
directly on him and really separates you
from the background and i love that that
compliments then later on because you
have it as a means of bringing them all
close together and really honing in the
peters on each other very true very good
point what i really do love is when he
looks back up at them and it just looks
like a comic book shot yeah where
they're in the shadows at the top of the
blue there's silhouettes back then like
giant moon they swing down and i really
admire that their first scene together
the three of them it's not a fun quippy
scene whatsoever no it's it's not
service-y it's a dramatic there's like
the fan service in terms of like they're
talking about certain things but it's a
really just great dramatic scene between
the three of them because this whole
20-25 minute stretch that we're talking
about you could pretty much dub peter's
lesson about great power comes great
responsibility that's that whole
run from from before ant-may dies to the
end of this scene when they're chatting
with each other
that to me is more rewarding than them
quipping that to me is more rewarding
than them having fun doing spider-man
stuff because this is peter parker's
talking with each other well using and
and resting upon all of the character
development and all the details that
have come in those movies before and so
it feels like yeah an immediate way to
go no no we care about all three of
these peters yeah but also we care most
about what's happening to tom's peter
right here and now yeah because tom
holland like he's the most alone out of
the three of them he doesn't have an
uncle ben he doesn't have an aunt me the
world is after him like the world is
after him i like of how he's he's just
he just he's not excited to see them
whatsoever he yeah just like just go
home i don't care anymore
they die in your universe
that's fine and so i love that it
becomes a true learning lesson for him
from learning of their experiences when
toby is talking with them about the
events of spider-man 1 when he went
after uncle ben's killer how you learn a
little bit more about the future of what
happened with andrew garfield post
the death of gwen stacy how it still
haunts him in his performance because he
says it will never get over it it still
haunts him and for him to talk about
like uh it you know like i gave into
this rage i started to change
uh
oh man i want to see that movie
yeah you start you get these shades of
that and then when they all kind of
connect together because he feels like
just because he feels we're both peter
parker's does not mean we're similar to
each other does not mean you could
possibly understand my experiences or
how i feel then when it the with great
power comes that line comes back and
toby mcguire fills in the blank andrew
garfield is the one who cites uncle ben
said even though it's not exactly how he
said an amazing spider-man you know the
same thing
i'm paraphrasing for uncle ben
paraphrasing my dad
so
when that says it that's from the moment
where the three are truly intertwined
and connected and they all learn that
lesson at a moment of one of the most
pivotal losses in their lives and it's
also the the driving home of the fact
that the two of them maybe didn't in
that moment you know of anguish have the
guidance to go now in this moment where
you're feeling the epicenter of the rage
the pain the sorrow the grief now is the
time where this lesson is the most
important because you might go off and
make a mistake that you will very much
regret or that could corrupt you beyond
repair and so it yeah it does going back
to that idea that it feels the most
meaningful kind of here to touch that
idea it really does because it's the
crucial moment yeah so i feel like that
whole chunk that we just talked about i
wouldn't change a thing about it no and
and i think it's really smart what they
did because they hid it between one
really heart-wrenching it's like we're
all thinking how are toby and andrew
going to show up it's going to be
awesome and we're going to hoop and
holler when they do and i think they
were very conscientious in putting it
right in the midst of both the crushing
loss of aunt may one of the lowest
points in the movies and one of the most
fun things with ned figuring out his
magic abilities and i think that's a
great way of kind of throwing off your
focus and sort of distracting you from
them and then letting their entry be so
impactful and it doesn't and what i love
too is that it doesn't undercut the
death of aunt may all it does is
actually because of the conversation
with the first time the three of them
together it further drives home the
importance and significance and the
weight and the missing presence of
ant-man now like it's it amplifies it so
that whole stretch is
like genius to me yeah there's a plenty
of other things that i was like yeah if
i was to make like a full-on list them
quipping about the spider web to toby
mcguire is always a blast yeah and the
web like that's that's such we'll get
more into that literally the last 10
minutes is almost like pretty like
that's pretty perfect to me
because it makes you go like oh wow they
pretty much use this mcu homecoming
trilogy to arc him into the spiderman
spiderman yeah he goes from being a
spider boy to a spider man
yeah it's really neat and it gives you
it really like obliterates all the
complaints that a lot of people have
shared with you know being like iron man
junior in a lot of ways well and it
lends credence to those previous movies
too yeah so you have that like there's
and like the the goodbye to mj there's
there's a gazillion scenes that you can
make a list about but in terms of what i
thought was perfect filmmaking that
whole stretch right there and it's also
to me more quintessential spider-man
arguments to be made for like other
moments for sure too
but to me that's this is the most
celebration of spider-man but yeah guys
thank you so much for being here what
was your favorite sequence from this
film leave your thoughts down below we
love it if you can subscribe click that
notification bell do keep a look out for
our live stream that we will be doing
this coming monday at 11 a.m pacific
standard time and yeah we will catch you
guys soon